[Music]
welcome to session 33 of the worlds of
speculative fiction
starting year four so that's pretty cool
and I decided this time around that
maybe it was time to go back to some
classic authors that everybody else
we've been looking at was was
referencing and I thought ho would be
one of those we're gonna do Chesterton
and and fret mary shelley and a few
others like that as well Before we jump
into our usual fare and pose somebody
that you know we all got introduced to I
imagine back when we were in grammar
school because you know they would have
us read the Raven or you know some of
his stories and he really made it into
the Canon of American literature he
wasn't quite so popular in his own day
and fortunately he wasn't well renew
Maury today things that he did and you
know we were talking a little bit about
the books at the start so I have these
like my great uncle Hubert I don't know
where he acquired these but these are
from what's left of his collection these
complete works of Edgar Allan Poe these
are from 1903 or two it's a little hard
to read but you know five five volumes I
only brought two of the volumes in
because I thought the ones in for the
poetry and the short stories would be
the most useful so you know I think as
usual I'll have some philosophical
themes to bring up all of you you know
I'm sure have quite a few other
philosophical themes to bring up as well
as I've put together some short passages
from some of his works that I think are
particularly interesting and we'll talk
about his biography which is fairly
short because he died pretty young
younger than me and much more history
both than I do but you know he had a
very interesting life
I don't know that we can talk that much
about world building this is something I
guess I should bounce off of all of you
at the start because we are often in
these sessions talk about you know the
fictional world that's created by these
authors and I don't know that we can you
know he does have this piece from near
the end of his life where he's
speculating about the universe Eureka a
prose poem but that's not really it's
not really fiction it's it's supposed to
be philosophy natural philosophy and you
know bits and pieces of it I guess show
up in his works but you know do you guys
think that there's a coherent worldview
or picture running throughout Poe's
stories ok grotesque I give an arabesque
you know
yeah Blake's I'm thinking what would be
Arab like or Arabia why would they refer
to that and I thought the only trail I
could come up with was like you know
something that's unusual or exotic yeah
this was that you know the Arabian world
was at that time so um but they were I
mean they they were the things that he
focused about focus I mean then they
just were it's hard this Victorian
language it's hard to pick that did you
well you know I wonder too because of
Poe having been assigned to us and all
of you got assigned Poe right when
you're in school and it might have been
a chore for us I know that reading it
today I I wasn't I wasn't like super
pleased or
I didn't have a great relish for his
phrasing and vocabulary and I like the
ideas in the stories but I - yeah I did
the language was so tedious to get
through that it was hard to focus on
actually what he was getting out you
know the whole thing in and there was
some really interesting themes that he
was trying to you know relate through
some of these stories
yeah and but you know when you're
reading at night meant I don't know you
just probably say way better than I do
but getting tired and it's like the
prose easier to get through because you
get used to the vocabulary that make
sense he really loves his long
descriptions of the furnishings and you
know he has a piece called the
philosophy of furniture I don't have any
of you ever read that one it's it's kind
of funny I mean it's it's not it's not a
story at all and I don't know exactly
where he published it because he
published things all over the place
but he talked so yeah this is this book
it actually begins with that and he says
that Americans are badly off because we
don't have an aristocracy of blood so
having therefore as a natural and indeed
in his inevitable thing fashioned for
herself an aristocracy of dollars the
display of wealth has to take the place
and perform the office of heraldic
display in monarchical countries so he
goes on and on about like how Americans
are so vulgar and and and you know use
the wrong kind of furnishings the
mistake as he says magnificence for
excellence and then he actually suggests
what he thinks a well furnished
apartment would look like Danny hates
glitter as he calls it he particularly
complains about the American pendency
lots of mirrors you know it spread
throughout a place and he says it makes
it confusing then he sketches out this
place it's like kind of dim and there's
rich crimson silk curtains fringe or the
deep network of gold he says line to the
silver tissue there's no cornices
there's there's rich gilt work so you
can start imagining this this room right
and then he says the colors of the
curtains and their fringe appear
everywhere in profusion and determine
the character of the room he goes on to
talk about the Saxony carpet and all of
that so he lays that what he thinks we
do wrong as a culture in decorating
outlines what good decoration would look
like and that's quite actually a
boardgame of it oh really
at the boardgame barrister okay but they
got the order of the colors of the rooms
correct oh good
all the House of Usher has some yeah
description Venice like they reunite
briefly and then yeah and another one
that has a lot of description of
backgrounds who is where it plays an
important role is purloined letter he
goes into the you know the taste of the
person's place and and you know the
reason why the letter you know doesn't
make sense where it is is because it's
deliberately kind of frayed up and and
stained so you you we've neglected you
know in a room that's so opulent and
well furnished so going back to the
question that is there a narrative the
universe I don't I don't know if there's
a narrative universe
a different she's looking at this girl
yeah who's looking at this world as not
as clean and pretty you know that kinda
reminds me do you guys remember that
show tales from the darkside from the
eighties I loved it intro to it because
it would talk about you know beneath the
the world that we see there's there's a
dark side and I forget exactly how I ran
but it was something like just like ours
but not so brightly lit yeah and that
would describe ho to me I just always
think of it as dark and Yammer's ways
but dark yeah you know some people call
him the one of the early figures of dark
romanticism we don't worry Romanticism
you've got this kind of optimistic
viewpoint and appeal to intuition and
you know the past and all that things
things can get better and better and
better and then you have these darker
figures who don't they're they're more
skeptical of it they think that that
human nature is more screwed up or that
the world is dingy or if not necessarily
dirtier than than the other romantics
you know it feels like he's depressed
much of the time that he's coming from a
depressed state of mind there's like
five out of the six different stories
that written here and everyone said he
hadn't lived where they aren't the
classics yeah he refers many times over
to this is like in an Opie injury he
refers to the phrase home in your dream
over and over again yeah so I was like I
opium dream oh well the guy was
obviously an opium user because he
refers to get so often and he refers to
it so descriptive maybe that he's been
there or temporary I think was one of
the Bronson bullet
we wrote something so well people
thought she had taken opium and she just
said no I used a lot of imagination so
if I can trust yeah well he might have
been there a few times you know he had a
literature to draw upon though I mean
Coleridge was already somebody big on
the scene and you know po knew him
through through sort of the intermediary
of American transcendentalist I think so
I don't know if that's a good question
well let's talk about his biography
because he had a pretty rough life and
you know if you want to understand him
as depressed I think that makes perfect
sense
given all the things that he people went
through as a matter of fact it's kind of
amazing he accomplished as much as he
did given all the challenges that he
faced so he's born in 1809 to this David
and Elizabeth Hopkins Po and David Poe
like leaves the year after that
they're both actors she abandons her and
a little Edgar and then his older
brother William and younger daughter
Rosalie and then just a year after that
his mother dies of consumption
tuberculosis they called it consumption
back then and he winds up being adopted
by John and Frances Callum is where the
Edgar Allan part comes from and he you
know he has a kind of tumultuous
relationship with with John Allen
sometimes he's really sometimes his
adopted father is really nice to him and
you know treats him very well and tries
to promote him at other times he
punishes him quite quite severely he
winds up being baptised with with them
in the Episcopal Church and you know I
think all of you know at that time that
really that was sort of like the top of
the Protestant hierarchy you know if you
were if you're poor you were probably a
Methodist or a Baptist and then you like
make your way up to the Lutheran's and
Presbyterians not exactly so and in a
place like Virginia that really mattered
quite a lot they relocate to Great
Britain and now you notice in his
biography he winds up going to schools
but he's on his own and he's you know
he's like six years old when he's sent
to this Grammar School in Irvine
well his adopted parents are in London
so you know he would you'd have been
with charges but I don't think he really
got much of an opportunity to do this
sort of bonding that that we typically
expect to happen in childhood and then
he goes into another boarding school
near London and that enters this manor
house school at a suburb of London isn't
part of that just the way they you know
they looked at children a lot
differently if you had means you would
be going to boarding school yeah but
also there wasn't the bonding wasn't a
big thing for a lot of people yeah
they're almost alien species yeah then
you voiced them off onto nurses or
tutors or people like that I don't
imagine you know that human nature has
changed that much
you think of what that must have been
like for a lot of those kids even with
you know sort of a that if we do that
right we said we sent off a kid say to
military school or boarding school
there's usually like this well you know
the kid must have done something wrong
sort of assertion and you're right that
wasn't there at the time but I think it
must have still been quite hard for him
I think mother's probably had more
objection but there's more the father
who would send them off and then one had
to get you laid to the man back in those
days
so if yeah what I'm sure was heard
around the mothers to have the children
shipped off but it was just sort of a
rite of passage for these kids to know
you know fathers the dance didn't want I
don't think he didn't want them around
you know they were just sort of taking
up the mothers time and I was his
property in you know there's all kinds
of if you were in the upper class the
lower class I didn't you know - I guess
with mortality being as high as it was
back then as well why invest an awful
lot of time and two kids that are you
know quite probably going to get to die
this barber if he talks about how when
he was adopted by the Allens the house
didn't have any children yeah and they
were merchants they weren't wealthy none
so late I'm too much later when they
heard it something but it sounded like
the father had a hot and cold
relationship on the one hand since his
wife didn't have any children this is
the only son he was in have yeah on the
other side it wasn't his real son well
my son
yeah so they went back and forth in
terms of how I treat him yeah how you
treat and then PO as he got older cause
his father lots of problems oh yeah yeah
well we're gonna get into that and and
just a bit but you know if you think
about he probably was a pretty you know
precocious smart kid and so those are
always challenging to deal with you know
now they eventually they moved back to
Richmond
seems like like Edgar is starting to you
know fit in pretty well and then like
you know like you said they only become
wealthy later on this literal rich uncle
dies William Gault and he leaves John
Allen a lot of a lot of land a lot of
wealth and around that same year
Edgar begins this relationship with
Sarah Elmira
royster and then you know he he goes on
and he enrolls at the University of
Virginia which was kind of an
experimental place at the time and it
really wasn't well put together it was
it was it was a Jefferson played a role
in establishing it and it was supposed
to be like a new kind of school the
students would have a lot of leeway and
Democratic participation in the school
itself but nobody quite knew how to make
this work and as a result it was it was
rather chaotic so when Edgar Allan Poe
goes there he winds up in in debt and
some of the debts are because he liked
to gamble and drink and things like that
but some of the debts were because
things were just so disorganized and so
he he starts getting estranged from his
father over these issues of debts his
father you know thinks that he's you
might say underperforming you know as in
a moral sense and at the same time Edgar
and Sarah secretly get engaged before he
goes off to school and her father
destroys the letters so she doesn't know
that
Edgar is writing him all this time she
thinks that he's going off to school and
he's just sort of left her and not
interested and
then she ends up marrying somebody else
he will he will run into her again later
in life
eventually he drops out of the
University and he relocates to Boston
and he starts doing a lot of writing
professionally works as a clerk and as a
newspaper writer Sarah gets married to
somebody else and this is when he brings
out his first poems and he's living
pretty hand-to-mouth
at the time he's not he's not making a
lot of income as a matter of fact he'll
be poor a good portion of his life and
then he enlists in the Army in part
because he's just not making enough
money doing doing what he's doing and he
lies about his name he unless says Edgar
a Perry and he lies about his age he if
I remember anything he said he was 21
years old at the time and he of course
wasn't it was 18 and very quickly he
moves up through the ranks no I don't
know exactly what this rank of sergeant
major of the artillery means clearly it
couldn't have been like a sergeant major
in the sense that were used to it today
but he's in there and then he decides he
wants to get out of the army so he goes
to his commanding officer and he tells
him hey I lied about my name I lied
about my age you can't actually hold me
to the oath you should you know get me
out of here and as commanding officer
says because his commanding officer
knows him pretty well by that time he
says I will let you go if you reconcile
with your father and so there's some
back-and-forth going on and Alan has a
sort of come to Jesus moment after his
wife dies but he also has conditions he
says I will let you leave the army and
I'll be reconciled with you but you're
going to go to West Point so in some
ways it's like going you know from the
proverbial frying pan into the fire
and and po goes to West Point and while
he's there at West Point he you know he
does continue writing you know he
doesn't just write poetry too he writes
satirical stuff about what the army is
like and eventually there's some some
new problems allen marries this this new
wife Louisa Patterson and gets into
quarrels with Edgar Allan Poe about that
and about other things as well and then
disowns him meanwhile Poe decides that
he wants out of West Point so he
deliberately gets himself
court-martialed which is a terrible way
to get out doesn't have quite the
effects that a dishonorable discharge
would today you know from from current
army because everything's you know
electronic now but it was still quite a
black mark and so he goes back to
Baltimore and he lives with his aunt and
his brother his brother ends up dying
post starts trying to live a Verna's
living as a writer and from that point
on he's he's basically doing that and
then sure after venture after venture in
effect fails some things will work for a
short time and then not work for a short
time he actually has a piece I don't
know if I have it in here where he
complains about how bad the people who
run the magazines are I don't know if I
brought that one with me no
unfortunately I didn't but it's it's
quite a good story he finishes it by
saying I'm not actually imputing the
character of anybody in real life all
the magazine people that I know are just
you know upstanding gentlemen and I'm
just going by what I've heard happened
to other people but you know it's
actually his own experience he talks
about like not getting paid for months
and months and months
finally getting letters back from them
saying we're about to publish your piece
and we'll pay you six months from now so
you know that that's that's pretty rough
he winds up getting some some prizes and
then he becomes the assistant editor of
the southern literary messenger gets
fired for showing up drunk to work and
then gets reinstated after after a
little while he also marries his cousin
and she's 13 years old at the time the
witness attests that she's 21 so she
probably looked a little bit you know
older than 13 but she was actually 13 at
the time he winds up you know working
for for a couple different magazines
different different points of time
burton's gentleman magazine grams
magazine and then one of his pet
projects that he never was able to bring
about he wanted to fund a new literary
magazine called the stylus even drew up
a prospectus for it and took out an
advertisement in the newspaper trying to
you know solicit funds to do this and it
you know he first started doing this
back in was 1840 that that is time when
he died in 18-49 still hadn't brought it
off it was still not a pipe dream but
you know just it wasn't it wasn't
happening
by that time he had already you know
published his first novel it was really
only novel and tried publishing a play
pollutant installments it got really bad
reviews so he just he gave up on that
and he 1842 his wife starts showing the
first signs of consumption and you know
there's a lot of people in his life who
are dying of that there's a lot of
characters who
ended up having that as well and you
notice he's becoming more and more
productive in terms of the stories I
didn't put all the stories in there or
all the poems I just put in the ones
that were particularly interested in as
science fiction ER or detective novels
but he starts drinking more and more
he's he's doing quite a bit of writing
he talks about writing taking him a good
bit of time too
so he doesn't have a you know - it out
kind of writing process that I think a
lot of other people that we've looked at
do or they could write thousands of
words per day the thing that makes his
reputation
besides literary criticism most most of
the what he's being known for at this
time is his literary criticism and he's
known as being a really tough mean
critic the you know bashes all sorts of
people
he's very uncompromising but he finally
writes this thing the raven and that
really puts him on the map and
originally he brings the raven to this
guy Graham who he had been working for
Graham was one of these people who was
rich has his own magazine and Howe work
for him as an assistant for a while
Graham declines the poem says that we
can't publish this but he gives him 15
bucks for charity and says you know take
care of yourself when 15 bucks is quite
a you know good bit of money at that
time Poe publishes The Raven and it
takes off immediately and then he's able
to publish the Raven and other poems
right and soon after that he's going to
start publishing things like the
philosophy of composition where he's
actually talking about writing the Raven
they they eventually moved to New York
and at that time it's now the Bronx
right because there's the five boroughs
but at that time Fordham or Fordham
University is this was a little Dutch
village and there were the Jesuits there
the Fordham University Jesuits now and a
bunch of other people around there and
they moved to this little place there
and that's where Virginia is going to
die of consumption after that Poe
doesn't actually wait that long before
he starts trying to court this poet who
will write a biography of him a theater
odd Sarah Helen Whitman and then he
returns to to Richmond and he meets up
with his childhood sweetheart
Sarah he also starts giving lectures and
one of the lectures is this thing Eureka
that that we'll talk about in just a bit
it doesn't go well that's you know
typical for for Poe but he is on lecture
circuits now he's giving talks and he's
starting to you know make some some
decent money from time to time Edgar and
Sarah they start to look at the
possibility of marriage her husband at
that time had died and the main thing
that kept them from actually getting
married other than the fact that her
kids weren't really big on the idea was
that there was a provision in her
husband's will that if she remarried she
would lose most of the inheritance and
so that you know that was a significant
impediment and just about I think it's
about a week after they're having these
conversations Poe is in Baltimore and
people find him in the streets just sort
of out of out of his head kind of kind
of raving he winds up at Washington
Medical College and there he dies and
nobody actually knows what he died of
there's there's different theories
clearly he had a drinking problem he
probably had diabetes at the time there
were probably a lot of other things
wrong with and we don't really know but
I mean people were dying all the time
of diseases back then anyway so you know
he's not really that old he's 40 years
old when he dies and you know if you
think about it he doesn't actually leave
that huge of a body work
behind it's a number of short stories
and essays and quite a few poems well
you know we've talked about with what's
there is sometimes frustrating to read
but there's a lot of really interesting
ideas built into it and that's that's
part of what I wanted to talk about in
this before we do that though I wanted
to talk a little bit about what happened
to his reputation afterwards and and at
the time so he's a contemporary of
Emerson and some people will contrast
the two of them because Emerson is this
big you know well-known
transcendentalist figure kind of an
optimist about human nature and the
universe and sort of the new person
coming out
Emerson really didn't like didn't like
poet all he called him the jingle man
and he thought that that his work was
kind of superficial I thought that poem
self was you know corrupt and you know
perhaps downright evil Whitman didn't
like Poe either
he actually said Poe was almost without
the first sign of moral principle or of
the concrete or its heroism or the
simpler affections of the heart so he
thinks that he also said that he was
among the electric lights of imaginative
literature brilliant and dazzling but
with no heat and electric light was a
bad thing back then right so there's
there's quite a few people who don't
like him then there's this guy Griswold
and Griswold you know we have people
like this today where they write these
towels and they are ready to air like
almost immediately after the person dies
or does something wrong or leaves the
office or whatever and Griswold did that
he published this piece about Poe that a
lot of people bought into and portrayed
Poe is like being a totally amoral
sensualist you know interested in Beauty
kind of like a decadent right
it probably didn't help that later that
a spy wasn't probably helped later on by
the fact that it was Baudelaire who
translated Poe into French because
Volare definitely was a decadent you
know have you read his poetry that's
that's quite clear but this this woman
who he courted Sara Holland Whitman
here's one of the things she wrote she
said we're ready to admit with the
severe critic of the North American that
a very large proportion of Poe's stories
are filled with monstrous and appalling
images many of them oppressed the reader
like frightful nqb from which influence
he vainly tries to escape
Ruskin tells us in his treatise on the
grotesque it's the trembling of the
human soul in the presence of death
which most of all disturbs the images on
the intellectual mirror investing them
with the grotesque ghastliness of fitful
dreams and he says if the mind be not
healthful and serene the wider the scope
of its glance and the grander the truth
of which it obtains an insight the more
fantastic and fearful are these
distorted images so she's she's saying
yeah okay Poe writes about horrific
stuff although some of its campaign
compared to contemporary or I think
right or even Lovecraftian horror but at
the time it seems kind of decadent and
you know morbid then she says yet as out
of mighty and terrific discord noblest
harmonies are sometimes evolved so
through the purgatorial ministries of
waa and terror and through the haunting
nemesis of doubt this is impose Restless
and an unofficial was urged down to the
fulfillment of its appointed work
groping up blindly towards the light and
marking the approach of great spiritual
truths by the very depth of the shadow
it projected against them so in and
growl and your poet has critics she's
defending him and saying he actually did
have some sort of moral project in mind
and you know he'll also direct people
towards some of these passages that I've
actually got here in the handout where
he talks about since Paul wasn't
entirely without that she also points
out to that for somebody who's not
supposed to have had a conscience
he sure he has a lot of stories in which
somebody is tortured by guns that's like
the tell-tale heart you know or the
black cat or there's another one that
she brings up as well so she's defending
him against against his critics and so
we've got this two-sided thing and I
think a lot of people today insofar as
Poe's still part of popular culture I
think that he's mostly associated with
that kind of you know dark brooding
morbid always looks at the bad stuff you
know if he's interested in beauty at all
it's like beauty of loss
melancholy as he says and and they they
don't look at the other stuff quite
quite so much but he's you know he's
really in the history of American
writing in the history of literature in
general he's very important because he
leads to the modern detective novel
Arthur Conan Doyle credits Pope he
writes some things that are clearly
science fiction like the case of mr.
Valdemar and he's definitely somebody
who's central in the horror genre as
well and you know I didn't quite realize
this until I started rereading his stuff
I gone through you know freight the
phase when I was reading a lot of poem
actually out of these volumes from that
what used to be my great-uncle's about
15 years ago and I was struck by how
much philosophical content there is both
in a sense of sort of broad
philosophical themes where ideas are
just being talked about but not being
attributed to a particular
thinker and then references that Poe has
to you know Plato Aristotle
Epictetus Pascal can't mill you know all
these different thinkers sometimes even
plays we're out of it like he says you
know mill wrote oh he has a character
who's like sent many years in the future
Eureka who says that you know there is
this guy mill and he wrote a horse named
Bentham Bentham was was an important
early utilitarian at Mills his successor
so clearly Poe you know was very
well-read knew quite a bit of what he
was talking about wove those those
things in and had a significant
influence on these these genres of
speculative fiction it's unfortunate
that he didn't get much recognition in
his own time what he did get was
primarily just for the reason you know
it's sort of like being who did I mean
is there anybody you could think of who
they they deserve to be known for like
their whole body of work but they got
known for just one song or one painting
or something like that I mean we talk
about one-hit wonders and music right
and usually one hit wonders really are
one-hit wonders they only have one good
song and that was that was it but
there's I think there's some there's
quite a few people who have really great
stuff but we don't know it until we buy
the album or though the CD you know or
go hear them in concert that allows
anybody come to mind of hand
well I think in terms of artists yeah
okay these sculptors and artists it's
not unusual to be known for the great
ones to maybe have some credit for one
thing and then after they die
Oh work yeah yeah I was thinking of
DaVinci because other dimension
Michelangelo Picasso you know he's so
you know later work but when you see his
earlier work which was all very
figurative and realistic you're gonna
look at any number of artists or today
considered masters yeah
but time was not considered important
reason I was talking about DaVinci skiff
he was primarily known for like the Last
Supper and a few of his frescoes but
hardly any of his inventions and all of
the other things that he was in his
sculpture and he did so many other
mediums and he was you know there were
there were some even some philosophers
like that David Hume is a good example
you know if you're taken into a
philosophy class you've got to run into
him and he's got all these important
thoughts about you know cause and effect
and association of ideas that that lays
the ground for association of psychology
but in his own day people knew him
basically is like a literary critic and
a historian and that's where he made his
money is writing this big history of
England no but that wasn't really where
his heart was his first book which
people look at now and I'm like this is
this is a work of genius he said it felt
stillborn from the press it was this
treatise of human nature he had it
printed at his own expense couldn't sell
the copies so yeah
yeah yeah I don't think too many people
in philosophy actually know Noah Smith
as something more than just the
invisible am guy you know they don't
realize he's part of that Scottish
enlightenment they call it you know the
Hume and Reid and all those people were
part of yeah it's too it's it's
unfortunate it's definitely not a fair
world isn't you know somebody else who
we've talked about in here since we're
on this topic of like being not being
recognized for what you'd like to do
philip k dick wrote these really great
realist novels couldn't get him
published in his day because he was a
science fiction author and they were
there I just quit doing this this stupid
stuff why don't you just write some more
science fiction stuff because we can
sell that and and actually the things
that are considered realist novels it's
not as if they don't have any science
fiction themes in them but nobody would
touch them you know and and he spent a
lot of time trying to sort of break out
of that I guess you could call it sci-fi
Gatto I mean he wrote some really really
great sci-fi stuff too but it's too bad
Paul actually wrote across genres you
know we've got some horror stuff he
wrote a lot of humor stuff too and
satires I wasn't really gonna talk that
much about about those and I didn't put
those into the list but he he had a kind
of a serb acquit you know when it came
to things well let's let's talk about
some some big big picture themes and
ideas so I thought that some of them
that were kind of interesting too
or death you know and how we how we
understand death it plays such a big
role in many of his stories another
theme is is people trying to escape from
their destiny or their fate but they're
never able to do so we follow the House
of Usher is a good example of that
there's also a lot that explore human
passions and motivations usually not
very particularly good ones you know the
violent ones he also you know talks
quite a bit about the nature of beauty
and why beauty is is so important and
some of the selections that I had here
go into that so maybe that's a good one
to jump into in in these two pieces the
philosophy of composition and the poetic
principle where he's talking about not
just his own writing process he actually
walks you through how he brought the
Raven interestingly enough in the
philosophy of composition yeah he tells
you I started with you know this this
thing in mind and then I that's that's
the goal or end and then I you know
started thinking about well what would I
do in order to get there and how do I do
that and how do I do that he walks you
down to the level of life well this is
why I use the old so often in this and
here's why I chose this meter and here's
why I chose a raven rather than
something else and then the word
Nevermore could could fit in for this
reason so it's it's quite it's pretty
interesting it's almost like you know
another thing he's known for is the
detective stories and a lot of his
detective stories are essentially
tracing out reasoning processes about
what would happen
what took place what must be the case
and so he's actually giving you a little
bit of a detective story about how he
came up with this this great poem but
let's look at this thing from the
philosophy of composition so he says
beauty is the sole legitimate province
of the poem I think a lot of people
would agree with with that you know
poetry is not necessarily in the classic
sense it's not necessarily supposed to
do anything other than make us you know
enjoy it produce some pleasure so he
says a few words in education of mine my
real meaning the pleasure which is at
once the most intense most elevating and
most pure is I believe found in the
contemplation of the beautiful when
people speak of beauty they mean
precisely not equality as is supposed so
it's not something that's in the thing
but in effect they refer to that intense
and pure elevation of soul not of
intellect nor of heart upon which I have
commented and which is experienced in
consequence of contemplating the
beautiful so I think that's an
interesting thing right there
he's talking about it doesn't have to do
with the intellect it doesn't have to do
with the heart
those are different faculties we'll talk
about that a little bit more later on so
he says I designate Beauty as the
province of the poem merely because it's
an obvious rule of art that effects
should be made to spring from direct
causes I'm going to skip through a
little bit of that they says the object
truth or the satisfaction of the
intellect and the object passion or
excitement of the heart are the although
attainable to a certain extent in poetry
far more readily attainable in prose you
can you can do that you know you can you
can satisfy the requirements of the
intellect much more easily in in prose
because you don't have to worry about
meter and rhyme and all this other stuff
so he says truth demands precision
passion a homeliness which are
absolutely antagonistic to that beauty
which I maintain as the excitement or
pleasurable elevation of the soul
he says it
and follow that passion or truth may not
be introduced even profitably introduced
into a poem for they may serve in
elucidation or aid in the general effect
bought the true artist will always
contrive first to tone them into proper
subservience to the preponderant aim
secondly to unveil them as far as
possible in that beauty which is the
atmosphere and essence of the poem you
know later on somebody like Oscar Wilde
will talk about art for art's sake right
and one of the questions that comes up
constantly is what is art for is and
with poetry where its language what
would as poetry is supposed to do is it
supposed to like teach us what kind of
people we ought to be you know it should
it be very didactic should it be like
consoling and make us feel good about
our situation should it you know we
think about other poetry should help us
to sell songs or should it help us to
get in bed with somebody people write
poetry for those reasons or should it be
to produce this effect of beauty it
should that be the one thing that
centers everything and for and for Poe
there's no sort of like well it's beauty
you know kind of sappiness or anything
like that with it he means something
that like almost electrifies you that
you know brings you into it as news of
the firm like enchanted circle but I
think you can't I don't know Carl that
next line young someone to tears doesn't
mean that their melancholy it means that
they're touched by something beautiful
will have to be sad yeah yeah this is
this is Paul
I think you're right about that so he
even in that essay takes kind of a turn
and I didn't include the other thing
that comes after that he says regarding
beauty as my province the next question
referred to the tone of its highest
manifestation all experience has shown
this tone is one of sadness now whose
experience right yes I think that ours
necessarily and you're right sometimes
like I find myself you know when we're
watching a movie or something like that
sometimes tearing out that stuff and I'm
like what the hell is going on with me
you know and some of it makes good sense
like I see somebody at a funeral for
their parents and you know I lost my
parents a long time ago sometimes it
brings up that sort of thing especially
if there's like music in the background
but sometimes I'll see somebody doing a
you know morally significant sacrifice
and I feel I feel can I like tear up
seeing it and I'm like what the hell is
this about
you know this is a good thing alright
but it's it's a it's a sort of affective
reaction to some kind of beauty you know
good actions really noble actions are
beautiful actions and they're being
depicted in an artistic way I don't you
know what some of its silly it could be
in a sci-fi show her some fantasy show
now he thinks that melancholy like you
said is the most legitimate of the
poetic tones so not just sadness but but
melancholy and then he goes on a little
bit further and he says the best way to
do this is with the loss of a beautiful
woman yeah
you know an expression of the soul I
mean words that you can't get out always
in prose you can not just you could just
manifest in poetry that's what it
basically is and that's why it's it's
something you have to just sit with you
can't just read it you have to really go
into it to discover what the poet is
really trying to say with that but
they're just sick and maybe he's
expressing melancholy because he's you
know he's that's where he's coming this
is an expression of his soul its beauty
but at the same time as coming from
artis yes
do we have any poetry though that's
really about the simpler joyful things
Whitman
yeah it's it's still a kind of a
melancholy about the beauty he sees as
impermanent yeah I'm Betty I mean he's
so exuberant yeah in his writing and
usually as a contemporary of poll most
poets I think of it's being honest right
yeah it is melancholic they frequently
writing in Elizabeth Barrett Browning
they're frequently writing about
lawsuits but there's a Yasir yeah it's
about emotion the deep hearts that you
just can't put in the other way I like
what you're saying though a little bit
earlier about you have to take your time
with it because I think I think you're
completely right about that you can't
appreciate what's going on in a poem
reading it on a timetable and that's
unfortunately the way that I think most
of us encounter poetry
it's either like you know we got it in
school and we're doing this poem this
day and we've got you know thirty
minutes of this fun you know and maybe
we also have to be like in the right
frame of mind so it's not enough just to
have the right amount of time maybe you
can't you can't read certain kinds of
poetry when you're distracted by
thinking about your you know grocery
list or you know filling out your taxes
or kids are doing sitting there and they
just pick it up every once in a while
and I just yeah I just like that
I'd like Mary Oliver supportive she's a
contemporary poet but she's she writes a
lot about nature and the natural
environment like her so I mean there's
just certain things sometimes there's
probably different poets for different
people like I you know I particularly
like Rilke and I can't read all of his
poems at any given time some of them are
more like demanding than others I think
but there there's some of his poems and
I could like like you were saying I
could you know any spare moments I could
pick them off and relate to them and II
my wife really really lost some more
schoo and I've read some of her stuff
and I don't get quite the same thing out
of it you know there's something I'm not
getting because the interpretation
sometimes is very subjective
yeah you know it and even though there
isn't there is some objective thing
there by the poor but it is subjectively
relating I mean I don't know that's just
I mean I'm not a student of poetry but I
just sort of blathering here but that's
just how I know but that's that's I
think that's important you know poetry
has become kind of a preserve right for
for academics and for the you know the
elites but one of the things that the
romantics were really insistent about is
that poetry should be able to reach the
ordinary person and if it doesn't I mean
it could require some elevate
right but but if it can't reach the
ordinary person there's something wrong
that's not that's not the ordinary
person's fault all the time it could be
the poet's fault
and I think a lot of contemporary poetry
you know it's just it kind of misses the
mark
a lot of it too is very either like
hyper personal or hyper political as
well and you know I I like you know
learning about other people's stuff but
I don't want have to like decipher
somebody's you know codes for all of
their little personal experiences
there's very few people I'm willing to
do that for you know this is this is
aiming at something a bit more Universal
but that's going back to the melancholy
effect yeah why does it have to be
melancholy why can't why can't it be joy
or anger or hope or something something
else anxiety maybe you know yeah you
know philosopher there's a little really
off track but there's the philosopher
who made a big deal out of emotions and
picked one as being like the emotion
that reveals being in the world to us as
was hiding her Martin Heidegger and he
said anxiety oxd this is you know he's
like one of the main existentialist
figures that's the one that reveals the
world to us
unlike other emotions and I always
thought that's kind of BS you know why
couldn't hope be just as as revelatory
of reality maybe maybe some emotions
like anger often gives us a distorted
view of things but when do we do the
most introspection okay it's not during
joy we could but we do me a little bit
yeah when we do the most
is during those times of strong anxiety
or negative emotion when we have to look
inside ourselves to figure out
I wonder where lace in the world and
what's going on we don't tend to wear
joyful when we're happy when we're
floating along we don't tend to do that
introspection and I think poetry gets at
some of that introspection yeah not that
there are not joyful poems don't you
think that maybe we could learn to
cultivate the capacity I mean that's
part of I think what maybe we should
some-some ascetic traditions do well
they're not like you know just fasting
or stuff like that they try to get you
to like actually feel grateful for the
fact that you're live and you know
spring has come or something like that
you see that it's virtually treats and
that kind of thing
yeah so if a person did that and they
did that over and over again then maybe
they would get more out of joyful poetry
you know or even poetry that you can't
quite realize as as joyful until you're
the proper frame of mind I have a friend
who's a poet but he writes haiku
okay which is entirely different to them
yeah style and approach yeah looking at
the world but it can have oh you know I
very strong of calmness I mean it's yeah
I think he listens lots of emotions yeah
you know another one that's a positive
emotion is oh or wonder right and that
could that could be we talked about that
was Louis yeah because his aw and joy
was very relevant too
yeah that's right yeah and we're gonna
you know Chesterton Louis we're talking
about Chester to next time are very
similar in that respect there are you
know they're both explicitly religious
authors but part of what's cool about
them is they're they're into a sort of
robust the world is a good place kind of
religiosity rather than like this kind
of DMV pamby you know let's all just go
to church and be gone thing coming back
to this so there's another thing here
with in terms of beauty and and these
other faculties that I just wanted to
hit on very quickly so this is from the
poetic principle and Howe talks again
about intellect and the moral sense and
then he talks about this this Faculty of
taste or discrimination or judgment this
is something taste was was not just like
having good taste and furnishings or
things like that but being able to make
good judgments at the time and he says
that dividing them the world of the mind
into pure intellect haste in the moral
sense I placed haste in the middle
because it's just this position which of
them in the mind it occupies it holds
intimate relations with either extreme
but from the moral sense it's separated
by so faint a difference
Aristotle has not hesitated to place
some of its operations among the virtues
itself but we we find the offices of the
trio marked with a sufficient
distinction so this is how they're
different
just as the intellect concerns itself
with truth so taste informs us of the
beautiful that's the province of taste
to tell us what actually is beautiful as
apart from what's you know maybe appears
beautiful a moment but isn't really
beautiful and the moral sense it has to
do with duty and he goes on it says of
this ladder the moral sense well
conscience teaches the obligation and
reason the expediency taste can
tense or soft with displaying the charms
waging war on vice solely on the ground
of their deformity and I think this is
really interesting because here he's
talking about something that addresses
his critics saying Poe is is you know
degenerate guy you know he's saying that
you wouldn't want to be vicious because
being vicious is ugly or it's it's
deformed there's something wrong with it
so he says vices got a disproportion
it's animosity to the fitting to the
appropriate to the harmonious in a word
to beauty so in a way if you want to
enjoy beauty you can't be a scoundrel
you can't be a Philistine you can't be
you know somebody who's motivated solely
by making money or attaining power or
any of those sorts of things so he says
an immortal instinct deep within the
spirit of man is a sense of the
beautiful this is what administers to
his delight in that manifold forms and
sounds and odours and sentiments amid
which he exists the struggle to
apprehend the supernal loveliness has
given to the world all that which the
world has ever been enabled that wants
to understand to feel his poetic and
they says to recapitulate I would define
and brief the poetry of words as the
rhythmical creation of beauty that's a
good good way to talk about it and then
he says its sole arbiter as taste so
again art for art's sake right the
intellect doesn't get to decide it can
have its little you know roll in there
but it's really poetry is not really
about satisfying the intellect nor is it
about satisfying the conscience
it's about satisfying our Faculty of
taste which would be something distinct
and you can imagine that maybe some
people who are really great intellects
could be totally lacking in taste or
some people who are really great people
you know in a moral sense might also
still be lacking in this this Faculty of
taste that it would have to be
cultivated in different ways and a fully
well-rounded person I
imagine would have all three of these
developed no not not just one or two but
all three so yeah I thought that was an
interesting discussion he had there
no what about these characters that he's
got who are pretty bad people what do we
make of them and their motivations does
that match up with this at all or is
there extra stories where the person in
the character is yes don't build you see
beauty okay I like look what which ones
do well I think the pendulum okay
house of wax because he's terrified
right yeah but there's no ability to see
beauty in his situation most of the
characters that are have some problems
or would be considered maybe immoral or
whatever do get punished yeah it's not
like he's promoting immorality morality
or evil or you know murder or anything
like that they all seem to get punished
yeah in the end mm-hmm yeah quite a few
of them like reveal themselves right
they they're tortured in some way it's
interesting is it's not it's not like
they have this direct conscience that
just you know convicts them or something
like that one of the ones that I wanted
to talk about is this this story the IMP
of the perverse and it starts out being
more like a treatise and then it turns
into a story how many of you guys read
that one so it's similar he's saying a
similar thing to what Dostoevsky in
notes from the underground is saying
that that we human beings we seem to be
very reasonable and rational and well
put together but there's something in us
that will sort of self-sabotage that
will undermine
ourselves and we can ask you know when a
person does it what do they really want
like you know you go to a psychologist
right and what is the psychologist or
counselor do what are you what are you
trying to do with this and they assume
that you're you know there's like maybe
a rational explanation underneath you
know I'm trying to please my dad or I'm
trying to you know trying to feel secure
or something like that
and PO says yeah okay sometimes that's
the case and sometimes we just don't
have any reason at all where we just do
the the stupidest things to do the
stupidest things
Dostoevsky has this underground man say
stuff like that after you know like
that'd be like what 40 years later 50
years later and and you know you could
think of it as kind of whim and post
says this is from the IMP of the
perverse in the consideration the
faculties and impulses the Primo Mobilia
the the prime movers of the human mind
phrenologist the people who would like
feel your spear your skull and tell you
about things failed to make room for a
propensity which although obviously
existing as a radical primitive
irreducible sentiment has been
overlooked by all the more or less who
preceded them in the pure arrogance of
reason we all overlooked it we suffered
its existence to escape our senses he
goes on he says the idea of it never
occurred to us simply because of its
super arrogation which means like it's
its superfluity you know it doesn't need
to to existing says we saw no need of it
we can have to perceive its necessity so
what is this he says it would have been
wiser it would have been safer to
classify upon the basis of what man
usually or occasionally did and was
always occasionally doing induction
would have brought rhinology to admit as
an innate and primitive principle of
human action a paradoxical something
which we could make all perverseness for
want of a more characteristic term and
now here's where it gets really
interesting he says in the sense I
intended it is a mobile without motive
so it doesn't have any
any reason to it it does move us he says
a motive not motive here through its
promptings we act without comprehensible
object or if this shall be understood as
a contradiction in terms
we could say that through its promptings
we act for the reason that we should not
so somebody says don't push that button
there's going to be some person who's
going to go over and push that button
and you can tell them you can like say
if you push that button the room will
fill with poisonous gas you know they're
like I don't really believe you well
here let me show you the movie and this
is what happened to all the other people
who push the button and most people you
know most of the time won't push the
button there's always going to be
somebody who's going to push that button
it gives you examples of people like
yeah well and the compulsion happens
when somebody says don't do that or this
said this would be bad for you to do and
you know we do we experience this I know
I've done some dumb stuff like that I
gave it to my great nephew last year for
his birthday called don't push the
button Oh is there a button down the
book there's a button on the book and
it's a board book it's got several
situations it's don't push the button
that's one of his favorite books cuz he
wants to push the button you know Bruce
Dickinson the the lead singer of iron
made and he I read his biography
there's autobiography recently and I
think it's it's titled something like
what does this button do or something
and he talks about himself as being like
the kind of guy who can't can't you know
not push the button you see that theme
in a lot of areas Doctor Who oh yeah the
last house oh that well the 11th doctor
Matt Smith was always talking about
wanting to push the button oh interested
in inner TARDIS yeah there was always
something about yes the red button I'm
fighting to push them yeah seem PO talks
in this he gives a couple examples
and I didn't put them on the thing one
of them is like being on the edge of a
cliff and like you know you shouldn't go
any closer to it but you know you're
kind of drawn to it and then you get to
the edge and you feel kind of sense of
vertigo because you don't know if you're
gonna throw yourself will offer that
you're like why would I throw myself off
of a cliff that's irrational well we do
dumb stuff we do dumb things when you
could get really close over oh yeah the
water goes right over I mean you could
get with that you feel it's water going
up going down and going over it's very
Wow I was there around that same time
when you could get really close yeah
interesting it's a very magnetic sense
he also talks about taking people off in
conversations going into like you know
that the person doesn't want to hear a
long-winded explanation but you do it
anyway and you as you can see them
getting more and more irritated you like
stretch it out even further you know why
is it perverse because we should want to
get along with people or we should want
to communicate effectively or something
like that right no cuz you know you're
doing something that's gonna take the
person off yeah do you know you're doing
something that's gonna make the other
person uncomfortable or irritated is
this what the whole theory of reverse
psychology came about no I don't know
but because you know at the very end of
that section of it he says something
quite quite interesting he says
examine these and similar actions as we
will we shall find them resulting solely
from the spirit of the perverse we
perpetrate them merely because we feel
that we should not right so there it
starts to you know it's always bad right
and they says be beyond or behind this
there is no intelligible principle and
we might even deem this perverseness a
direct instigation of the Archfiend
were it not occasionally known to
operate in furtherance of good every
once in a while because somebody's
perverse they actually do the right
thing that would be that he can't help
but pull the dangling chain okay so you
know somebody leaves an opening he can't
help but pull the chain and won't they
something that he knows the other person
is gonna be a little uncomfortable about
not bad things but yeah you know
especially our current political
environment Oh somebody who's kind of he
may deliberately say something that
caused him to think yeah it may not
trust him to think it may just cause
them to react yeah yeah yeah I was just
thinking it you know it wouldn't it be
interesting we figured out a way to
harness this for pedagogy you know but I
don't know how you would do it I mean I
did students every once in a while who
wanted it they had weird motivations and
they were gonna like write a really long
paper to show me
and it turned out to be quite good you
know I don't think they're aiming at
that but it would the only way you can
use it is if you could predict there
were the people who could who would
always do this
we do the opposite or the perverse by
its very nature you can't that's it so
yeah you could it's it's sort of like
perversity
well he sort of hints in here as if it's
it's something that is because we're
living beings it's part of our vitality
it's part of what helps us out and you
know if you think about if we if we
didn't if we only did what was
reasonable all the time I'd be like
robots so maybe it does help every once
in a while to deviate from our
programming experience how many us did
not do stupid things when we were
younger I did a lot of stupid things I
said how many of us could say we didn't
do stupid things when we were young I
probably didn't push as human beings and
you see that the children as they grow
and young adults one of the things I did
when I was a kid so I I had a boombox
and I was out in the garage that we had
a long extension cord and I was plugging
the boombox in and my my thumbnail
punched the tide of the the plug right
and it went in and I got a shock and it
hurt because it was like out of ten
poles and then I was like I was like is
that really an electric shock let me try
it you know I think of like my realm of
experience just because I was
a real person that did everything there
wasn't the sort of oversight that that
kids well I didn't I didn't have any
parents or boundaries so that I just my
whole world was just experience well
yeah there are people who just have
grown up in very small worlds yeah Artie
I've always heard this
whenever you're outside the bell curve
when you're you're out you know that
most people are in here and they think
no but when you're on the outside it
doesn't matter what it is what an aspect
it is but when you're outside you have a
much better view of what's going on to
the people who are in the middle and so
I was I always like being on the outside
of many issues because even though you
could feel a little alienated you were
still able to get this broader picture
yeah why are you learning the more
you're able to relate and doing all
these other things the more experiences
you have more you can you know just I've
been going back to poet you could say he
was an outsider yes that's all the time
a lot of those characters are too you
know like in the purloined letter the
way that the guy is able to do you know
you have to get this letter that's got
compromising information this person has
disguised it as like in plain view as
this other letter so he goes through
this sort of strategic reasoning process
thinking about what would how would
another person reacted this this
situation and how should I do these
things and he plans it all out
and he's able to do that precisely
because he's one of these outliers you
know he thinks about what an ordinary
person would do and he does the opposite
you know and that's sort of the whole
point of the purloined letter thing the
ordinary person like the cops they go in
and they look for things that are out of
the ordinary and they overlook this
letter that's just sitting there kind of
a turd that has all the incriminating
information in it you know what do you
see it with Sherlock Holmes yeah outside
the bell curve yeah
with Holmes his met his methods of
detection our he talks about his
deduction but it's not deduction at all
it's all induction or what we call
abduction where he's like you know sort
of inference to the best explanation he
goes in and he sort of like starts
looking for clues right this leads to
this leads to this leads to this and if
it was deduction there should be
necessary connections between all the
things they're not there aren't yeah
yeah one of the other themes let's talk
about the death theme a bit before we
run out of time so you know what is
death and how does it connect up with
with the living that's something that
gets portrayed a lot there's characters
who get buried alive of course well it
was a it was a fear of the time don't
worry they never read before yes I was
reading and even if these stories I had
never heard of and they're all just
really bizarre so I don't remember a lot
I mean I remember some of the old real
popular yeah everything I read in here
someone was buried alive we came back
and what the only ones that I had read
before was like gee I begin and I and I
never seen that movie and a creep me out
but you know coming back no scratching
on the coffin and all that not that be a
particularly horrific way to go you know
because think about you your first year
you're perceived as dead by everybody so
they put you in a coffin and put you
underground
now you do get to die after first
their coffins and if there's a I'm still
alive go in the graveyard they hear a
little bell ring and say okay dig that
guy up there there are some stories
where like the the case of Valdemar
where who is is he talked about using
Mesmer's on me today to keep keep
somebody that's sort of at the threshold
of death but but the character who's
who's dying actually does die and he but
he's able to speak and he tells the
people he's dead so that means that
there has to be some sort of existence
after death
which you know that sounds really great
because oh you've wonderful there's an
afterlife yeah but it's a crappy
afterlife you know it's a you're you're
in this nothingness you know you're
you're basically like one step away from
total non-existence and you know
Epicurus had this really interesting
argument why we shouldn't fear death if
you do know that one so Epicurus and
there were other people who said this
don't worry about death at all because
if it's you know by the time that it
happens to you there's no you right
death is the cessation of your existence
so there's nothing to fear there's
nothing to suffer there's no you after
that for Poe there is still you there is
still experience but it's not a good
experience and the debt the debt are
somehow like still connected to living
but not enough not in a positive
productive way the only way it's
positives like somebody's remembering
their dear departed you know loved ones
or things like that but one of the one
the loved one comes back from the grave
it's never good you know even even
though they they're happy in some
respect to see the raw change yeah
exactly
they're physically change their
emotional eat changed like an ED the
story there
like gia that yeah that one yeah so
someone love you know what would look
like geo since this perfect woman then
she dies and then he remarries and yep
she here
here's her scratching around and all of
a sudden there she is and takes out the
second way do you know yeah that's like
but when she came back she with the
beauty that he described her in the
beginning like she was just perfect
thing that wasn't what was there came
back there are multiple authors and
written stories about the convey that be
careful what you wish for
yeah no Paul yeah the stories about
genies and wishing on the lamp and
things like that bear true wish for some
of your lovely to come back there's a
mythology around the three princes and
the you know he wishes for his lover to
come back and she comes back yeah
but she's dead you know she just she
said not what she was what was it that
he said in lots of literature Stephen
King you know who traces Stephen King
places himself in this lineage in one of
his early essays where it's he you know
drew upon Lovecraft who grew up on Poe
so he's sort of like you know pose
something like that he's got that line
and Pet Sematary sometimes dead is
better you know well yeah he does it
with when the pets come back yeah yeah
they don't fully come they don't come
they're not the pet yeah I think a lot
of people imagine death and this is
something I've seen like you know
attending a lot of funerals including
some of you know close relatives people
want to have these consoling things like
oh you know they're in a better place
that you know I remember when my mom
died people I I ticked a lot of people
off because I was in the receiving line
at the funeral for like six hours and
towards the end some of her friends that
were coming through and say things like
oh she's she's an angel up in heaven now
and I was like that's really terrible
theology human beings don't become angel
we don't know she's in heaven it was
like shake my Anna get the hell out but
I think it's because they do have this
idea that there's like there's the
person as this disembodied soul and they
remain exactly the same untouched by the
experience of death and our TV shows
portray like alright somebody there's
there's like the there they're kind of
like a ghostly presence you know but
they otherwise look exactly the same
they have all the same mannerisms
whereas with Poe death really changes
you you know and experiencing other
people's death even even changes you
know I think a lot of people in our
society don't know how to handle death I
think that's why people look to the this
concept of the afterlife for consolation
yeah they don't know how to handle death
because people don't know what to do we
don't know I mean all of this is all
everything we make up whether any kind
of religious they're in this all human
constructs it just explain the
unexplainable I mean yeah I think in
terms of dealing with the loss right and
it's hard to deal with a loss if you can
tell yourself you'll be joined again you
will see them again if you believe that
actually can't be a counter break
consolation when you're experiencing
this loss of someone you love so
desperately yeah I have an excited
interesting experience if you don't mind
me an adult indulging me in something
that happened back in September I was in
London
I'd flown there to speak at a conference
and then I was in the airport flying out
and I wanted to get my I like English
breakfast so I was at this place where
you can actually get like an English
breakfast and is very you know sort of
upbeat music playing and I'm sitting
there and I'm reading some stuff and
eating and then Paul McCartney saw a
wings on came on
and I don't remember exactly what it
might have been the love song won and my
dad was a huge wingspan and I was
sitting there in the airport and
thinking about you know like how weird
it was that not only had I outlived him
he died when I was 11 but then I was way
older now than he ever made it to be
with he died when he was 36 and he died
in 1982 and then I was thinking about
like all the things that he's missed and
I wasn't like doing the oh he missed my
graduation I was just thinking like he
missed cellphones you know he missed
being able to get from Delafield to
Milwaukee in less than an hour because
he used to have to do that commute every
friggin day you know and back then it
was an hour and and I and and then I
what here's the sort of payoff I was
thinking about all this and I was
thinking about what he looked like and
and what it was like to relate to him
and I you know I'm not an 11 year old
kid anymore I'm so far from that I can
barely remember what a lot of that stuff
was like and I thought how weird that
he's still in a sense with me in such a
vivid way even though he's been gone for
three quarters of my life and this may
be the only way he still exists you know
I mean he the coordinated his own views
he didn't believe in heaven or hell or
anything like that he was kind of an
agnostic he still does exist in mind
yeah
but I thought to myself well how strange
is it that we human beings decades later
can be caring now of course what I'm
carrying around is probably only just
like the slimmest you know shaving of
his knee imagine yeah
but the fact that we actually can do
this isn't it kind of miraculous that we
you know the phrase you don't die people
remember you there's a phrase yeah I
mean like you know something else that
has happened to me over time because my
mother died thirty years ago or so and
what I have found is not only do I carry
around this memory of her yeah the
memory whatever her existence was has
actually been enhanced as I've reached
these different ages and been able to
meet the answer oh now I know why she
did that yeah now I know you know what
she was experiencing and that it just
like actually enhanced her whole being
for me and became closer to her in that
way so yeah there's something really
paradoxical about yeah yeah my dad died
two years ago in a traumatic way oh so I
had been dreaming of him coming back and
it's always kind of interesting it was a
closed casket funeral so I didn't get
the closure away yeah yeah he's actually
dead so for awhile I'd have nightmares
like oh no it was look at mistake and we
buried the wrong body so he'd come back
alive yeah and that was always really
gothic but even though I sort of feel
like my subconscious is trying to work
things out yeah it's like it's not you
have that lack of closure thing that
easier I mean it's not a happy
experience either it's almost like
Ingrid Allan Poe like why you're not
supposed to be here even if I be glad to
see you it's just so yes mixed emotions
right yes yeah you know when my dad died
I like the week after I had a dream
where he like drove back up we had he
had we had a station wagon at the time
so I drove back up in the station wagon
and came in the house and we were all
very surprised to see that because we
just had the awakened stuff and he he
was kind of puttering around you know
like in the kitchen and stuff like that
and then we're trying to talk to him and
he was just kind of preoccupied and then
he like turned and he said I gotta go I
you know see you later
and took you know and I woke up from
that and I felt I felt kind of pissed
off what the hell was that you know and
I I knew enough about like you know
dreams and the subconscious at that time
to I figure out all I'm trying to like
make sense of this and then I thought
why the hell would I give myself a
stupid dream like that why not give but
why not give myself a better dream you
know I can't really details but
something about him telling me things
were all right always and at the time I
don't believe in an afterlife presently
and at the time Minister I had was like
oh well he was telling you that
everything's fine and he's you know he's
he's out there and he you'll see him
later and I went no and her response was
well no wonder you're grieving so hard
if you don't believe you'll see him
again
interesting mmm you don't grieve his
heart she hurt her boy her feet
was the belief that you will see someone
again afterlife helps to ease the grief
a lot of people it does a lot of people
it does I'm sure but for me I never
believed in they half her life so no
that had nothing to do with how hard I
was grieving yeah for me you know and
you could think about like if you really
do believe in the afterlife and sort of
what's call it old time religion it's
not a consoling thing because you know
whether you take like you know
Christianity or say you know Buddhism or
something like that where you can be
reincarnated well you know most people
have probably lived a pretty crappy life
morally speaking so they're gonna wind
up in hell or you know yeah they're
gonna be reincarnated into some some
other place you know how do you know
you're gonna run across them maybe you
will maybe you'll both be in Hell
together and like suffering still there
and I mean I I can feel stuck my
daughter can see things which is just
and there's people who can I mean she's
she sees people has conversations and
you know freaked your friends out for a
while but if they just got used to it
and you know she's like was she moving
into a house on the east side and she
kind of meet the guy who built the house
and she had this name and everything
should go look it up and there it was
figure this stuff on you know yeah we
just had to live with that growing up
with her because she just always always
saw people and I've got a few unusual
experiences that I would know that's a
very unusual experiment
so you have a lot of death we had like
five deaths and when you're in somewhere
very hard and almost really hard in my
husband and he had he had some wonderful
experience you know with his sister so
you just I don't know if you have to go
what we to it or whatever but as far as
hell or a heaven no so let me let me ask
you think I think it's just different
energy form do you think that so you
know on the one hand we have like
certain theological explanations of
things or you know ministers consoling
us or things like that and then we have
speculative fiction where there's all
sorts of ideas like in Poe you know
clearly there's there's something that
survives but we have a lot of other
authors that we look at does any of that
help us figure not not giving us a
blueprint cuz obviously it's fiction but
does that even give us ideas for like
how we could look at our own death or
the death of others or I think it helps
us think through well you may or may not
believe it helps us rash you know wait a
rational think me not the right word but
I see it as a way to think through
issues and situations and I've always
I've got a lot of friends who do not
like science fiction or speculative
fiction
they think it's escapist I'm superfluous
you know not worth their time yeah and I
trust not serious yeah explain to us
what my husband feels he does not
understand my husband worries doesn't
stand it at all doesn't understand
science fiction doesn't interest me
it isn't interested in watching it and I
try to explain to them that's really a
good science fiction author with special
fiction author there's some pretty deep
stuff yeah in the stories and pretty
deep discussions that yeah about that
you if you think about it that leads you
to think about all sorts of things
afterlife whatever the morality how we
relate to each other as human beings
there's there's some really deep stuff
in in
regular fiction but so many people don't
see it they see it as silly or you know
just escape this woman I mean admittedly
some of it is the space opera wonderful
Star Trek episode where the two last two
men on this world were fighting to the
death because one was black and white on
his white and black obviously that was
taken off there was uh there are
Twilight Zone episode yeah well if you
read Gene Roddenberry's biography
autobiography he talks about he did he
sold the series to the studio as Cowboys
in space yeah you know a hero and he
deliberately went into it intending that
every episode should have a moral
undertone to it some kind of something
about racism or gender or whatever you
know something that I read about
recently and we were very far afield
from opponent but that's my about Star
Trek was that one reason that it was
difficult for the writers is Roddenberry
insisted that because it's this few you
know futuristic sort of utopian setting
that the none of the bridge officers
should be in any sort of deep conflict
with each other they have some things
like McCoy and Spock you know spar back
in Florida heart and my exactly no
personal grudges nothing like none of
the stuff that we have in normal dramas
Roddenberry with you on that he gave
every writer an outline and said this is
how this character behaves do not stray
from it Oh interesting is it this is
who's [ __ ] is this is who Kirk is this
is how they behave no bunch of turds see
what they believe whatever you write
yeah don't stray from this model of the
of the universe of the Star Trek
universe and the care
actors will head be tough too right
there yeah and I remember Melissa
Snodgrass who wrote one of my favorite
episodes which is the measure of a man
how how to determine whether data is as
a individual is a property from of Star
Trek and she said that she had to write
Roddenberry told her that in the future
in this glorious future that he had
there would be no lawyers there would be
no need for mayor so they have to
actually have the regular crew act as
lawyer prosecutor all of that in this
episode because it couldn't be anybody I
hosted I'm sure was also saving money
but but you know that's funny though
because in the new generation it begins
with like the queue problem right and
doesn't he put them in a try court right
oh yeah the jury is a group of people
yes but they were all cute they're all
cute they must have had fun with the
costumes something went but yeah well
it's not that far from home because Paul
writes with something in mind yeah he's
got morals he's got his tails the
viewers get their just desserts
you know all of his tail it really is
though about about power about so
necessarily beauty it could also be
horror right but these are aesthetic
rather than primarily moral emotions I'm
here to yeah sometimes yeah okay you can
do something really negative
it reflects what's a positive image good
Dorian Gray yeah exactly
I said an image can be any of you if you
see the worst in somebody you can see
what could best could be one it is
translator in his poems tries doing that
I mean
both layers you know writing about how
roadkill could be could be beautiful I
mean it doesn't call it roadkill because
there wasn't one kill at the time but he
talks about a you know dead animal
corpse rotting and you can see the
maggots and stuff like that but he's
trying to do it such for hits as the
poetry itself is really a full he does
it with a you know quite a few other
images of his own as well and maybe he
got that from Paul well is there
anything any other themes that you guys
want to hit on before they kick us out
of here so I know we're getting close to
time I was reflecting on he had such a
tragic life yeah and how much of his
poetry stories were tied to just the
kind of tragedy in his life because he
really had a tough life and part of it
was his own doing with the drinking and
this this authors suggest we had a
volatility yes and this obviously Jesse
had affairs
yuichi during his life so he wasn't the
most moral person yeah so you know but
you have to wonder I think an author
reflects their own life sometimes in
what they're writing they can't help it
I don't think they can help it well
definitely the theme of the beautiful
woman who's you know disappearing dying
and that sort of thing is central he
makes fun of the army you know that
comes up in his humorous things there's
actually one story that I thought would
be kind of hard to talk about where it's
what was the name of it the the man that
was used up didn't have you read that
one
she's a general if I remember right and
he has to be like most of him is press
the prosthesis and he has to be put
together each day by his manservant
and it's because of these wars that he
fought in against Indians and he lost an
arm here and a hand here and all that
sort of stuff and critics take it as
being sort of pose making fun of the the
military you know martial manly ass back
to the saying these that these K these
guys are kind of hollow man some people
take it as like PO you know worried
about a technological age that we're
moving into and things are going to be
you know we could be replaced by the
machines but it's it's I mean it's an
interesting piece or is it speculating
on you lose pieces of yourself as you go
through life well especially if you give
them scraps of people right yeah perhaps
the people you know he's a heavy drinker
you lose yourself to whatever he does
the liver transplant something Wilson
really okay so it comes off that this he
starts off saying he's really a perverse
terrible man or the guy and he's just
he's in school and he's he goes off to
school and he he meets this other
student who's got the same name and
basically he's paralleling this except
he's really good so in every trait that
this one past he's got the good tree and
the right break down to the you know
everything his keeps thinking you know
he he doesn't understand why this man
was sold and then like the last line it
was William Wilson all right yeah
I know you probably think I hadn't read
this one before
and then they somehow get in this this
fight with with a sword the the good
William Wilson says you have conquered
in a yielding yet henceforth I thought
also dead dead to the world to heaven in
to hope in me dis da we exist still hate
this language death see by this image
which is thine own how you have utterly
murdered thyself so you know he ends up
basically killing off the good part of
himself you know he just he was such he
saw himself with such a terrible human
being even when he could see himself as
good through the mirror of this other
man he and ended up having to kill that
part off
language in yours yes
well next time we'll do Chesterton
[Music]